hi my name is Carlos Brody I'm going to
tell you about a research effort funded
by the National Institutes of Health
within their brain initiative in which
seven different research groups have
gotten together to work collaboratively
to try to solve a problem that we think
is too big for any single group to solve
on its own as a team we call ourselves
brain cogs and you're going to hear six
different snapshots of the work going on
within this broader project we'll start
with an overall introduction from me and
then we'll dive into the six more
detailed snapshots we're interested in
how working memory and decision-making
are implemented in the brain so let me
take you through a quick example of
working memory and decision-making
suppose that you're playing a game of
tic-tac-toe I'm going to flash a screen
of a game of tic-tac-toe of one turn and
I'm gonna ask you after the image is
gone to think to yourself where would
you play if you were playing close so
here comes the image of the tic-tac-toe
game okay as you looked at that and then
thought to yourself where you would play
you were using working memory you were
maintaining information as to what the
state of play was as to what the
tic-tac-toe board looked like you are
manipulating that information as you
thought should I play mico here or here
or here and as you used that information
held in working memory to consider
available options you committed to one
as you decided where to play how are
these key processes which we use so much
in our everyday lives implemented by
neural circuits and neural dynamics
within the brain that's what we're
interested in the reason to believe that
many different brain regions across the
entire brain are involved in these
processes and that's part of why we
thought that we would need a team of
different research groups working
together to address the problem any one
brain region can be very complicated and
interactions between many of them are
more complicated still but maybe
together we can make headway we use
rodents in our research because there
are many powerful neural circuit
analysis tools that enable us to address
the issue in great detail so what are
the groups that have gotten together
let me take you through them David tanks
group Alanna Witten's group and Sam
Wong's group have all been involved in
developing advanced record a recording
and perturbation methods in rodents
david tanks group is particularly
interested in the function of the
hippocampal formation and cortex Elana
Witten's group is particularly
interested in the function of the
ventral tegmental area and the striatum
and Sam Wong's group is particularly
interested in the role of the cerebellum
in cognition Sebastian Seung's group is
leading efforts to link physiology and
cellular resolution connectivity
recording the activity of individual
like many individual identified neurons
and then taking that very same tissue
and figuring out exactly which neurons
connect to which so with that
information together we can make headway
in understanding how that neural circuit
ticks we also have two computational
neuroscience groups jonathan pillows
group who lead efforts on advanced
statistical methods to analyze neural
data
animart Goleman's group who leads
advanced by a physical modeling of
networks of neurons both within and
across brain regions and finally we also
have my own group we've been interested
in working memory and decision-making in
rodents for a long time now I told you
that we use rodents sometimes we use
mice sometimes we use rats
neither mice no rats can play
tic-tac-toe so what is it that we
actually do I'll take you through two
examples of the behaviors that we study
in the rodents in the first one that we
won that we call the accumulating
terrorists task we use mice within a
virtual reality setup that was developed
by David David tank lab back in 2009 the
mice are sitting on top of a Styrofoam
ball that is held up in a bed of mayer
and so it's very easy to move and as the
mice run and moved their feet the ball
moves and the motion of the ball is then
used to drive a projection of an image
on a screen that surrounds the mice that
way we can have a virtual reality system
for the mouse well the head of the mouse
is held perfectly still holding the head
of the mouse perfectly still is
important we
that means that we can use microscopy to
look inside the brain and record neural
activity while the mouse is behaving so
what's the behavior that we have the
mouse I do as I told you we call this
the accumulating Terrace task the mouse
runs up the stem of virtual teammates
and as it runs up that stem white towers
appear to the left and to the right of
the mouse and when it gets to the very
top of the stem the mouse has to decide
which of the two sides had the greater
total number of towers and it should
turn to that side the side that had the
greater total number of towers and if it
turns to the correct side it gets a
little water droplets a reward and then
the next trial starts so why did we
choose that particular form of task well
because in order to do this they need to
use working memory and decision-making
they need to accumulate how many towers
they've seen at every moment in time as
they go that means that they're
maintaining the tally of accumulated
Tower so far and when a new tower comes
up they have to manipulate that tally by
adding one to it either for the left or
the right so they have to maintain and
manipulate information and then when
they get to the top of the stem and make
a decision as to where to go left or
right they have to use that information
held in working memory to commit to one
of the available options and make a
decision so this is a simple form of
working memory and decision-making that
is nevertheless very quantifiable and
that is quite suited to rodent so that's
what we use here's what it looks like
from the mouse's point of view as you
can see they run quite fast they do this
a lot they do hundreds of trials per day
so they're very used to doing this and
they do it quite reliably now we don't
only use the accumulating towers task we
have other variants of the task that
you'll hear about in the talks that come
in a few minutes another variant of the
task is one that we call accumulating
puffs and once I'm going to show you is
that formally it's identical to this
task but it has different sensory
modality as an input and a different
mode of response as an output so that
means that by looking at what's common
across the two tasks we can understand
what are the fundamental cognitive
aspects and by looking at what's
different we can understand what are the
things that are
to the sensory modality that's the input
or the motor report that's the output in
the accumulating pups task the mice are
stationary they're not in virtual
reality and as they are stationary their
heads are also fixed that we can use
microscopy and while they're there they
get air puffs little pulses of puffs of
air to the right into the left whisker
pads at the end of the air puffs they
get a sound that is the go cue they have
to make their decision now and their
decision should be which of the two
sides have the greater total number of
puffs and depending on that they look
either to the right or to the left of a
lick tube and that's linked in the
correct direction to get a water drop as
a reward so as you can see it's also
accumulation of pulses of evidence in
the accumulating towers it's visual
evidence in accumulating puffs it's
somatosensory evidence the puffs on the
whiskers and the motor report here it's
not turning to one side or the other but
licking to one side or the other so they
share that formal structure but they
differ in sensory modality and motor
report all of the tasks that we use in
this in this project are what we call
the accumulating X variety they all
share that formal structure and that's
what binds all the different efforts
within the project together now as I
said we're taking an integrated brain
wide view so there are many people in
the project across the seven different
research research groups doing
experiments in many regions of the brain
there's also several people doing
modeling and data analysis and several
people working on technologies that are
used throughout the entire project we're
not going to tell you about all of the
work that is going on each of these
people leads an independent project
looking into these processes today we're
gonna focus on six different stories
that are all part of this big project
and they're all tied together by all
working on accumulation of pulses of
evidence here's a picture of all the
people currently working on the project
the seven different group leaders that
are introduced to you before are all
based at Princeton University except for
one
mark Goldman who is based at the
University of California at Davis
our first speaker is going to be dr.
Lucas Pinto who is currently a postdoc
in the tank and Brodie labs at Princeton
one of the big problems that we face as
we think of the relevant brain regions
for working memory and decision-making
is identifying which are the relevant
brain regions both in terms of their
neural activity and their causal
contributions to the processes Lucas
decided to address this problem by using
high throughput methods to examine both
neural activity and causal contributions
across all of dorsal cortex for working
memory and decision-making Lucas will be
starting up his own lab at Northwestern
University quite soon for now here he is
telling you about the work that he did
as a postdoc at Princeton decision
making can come and many different
flavors for example if you're driving
and traffic on a clear day and you
encounter a red traffic light it is
pretty easy to decide when to stop but
if it's raining torrential 'i out and if
it's night you might have a much harder
time distinguishing the red traffic
lights from the rear lights in the cars
such that you might need to stare a bit
longer through your water splash
windshield before making a decision so
this very simple example serves
illustrate the fact that even when
decisions have the same behavioral goal
or the same appropriate response towards
that goal begin very widely in terms of
their complexity and perceptual
difficulty more generally decisions can
have many different underlying
computation so for example on declared a
low-level sensory processing of the red
traffic light might be enough to trigger
the appropriate action of stepping on
the brakes whereas on a rainy night one
might need to add intermediate I'm
extended computations to accumulate the
noisy sensory evidence that is coming in
through your water splashed windshield
there are many other relevant
computations for decision making for
example another very commonly studied
one is decisions that require working
memory that is maintenance and
manipulation of either sensory
information or information about the
action that the subject is required to
take before actually executing that
action so in the experiments I'm about
to describe to you what we wondered was
whether the activity patterns occur
many areas of the cerebral cortex
changed when decisions require different
underlying computations
more specifically we hypothesized that
more complex decision-making tasks
involving working memory would result in
more widespread recruitment of different
cortical areas so in order to do this we
trained mice to perform decision-making
tasks while navigating in virtual
reality so more specifically we trained
them on three tasks that all occurred
and the same t-shaped amis and here
their job is to run down the maze and
turn either left or to the right to
retrieve a reward and across all these
tasks what informs where the reward is
is is stimuli that the animals see as
they traverse Tamizh but across the
different tasks that are required to
perform different computations on these
very similar stimuli so the more complex
tasks that we train them on was the
accumulating towers task that requires
the gradual accumulation of sensory
evidence and therefore working memory so
as animals ran down this virtual
t-shaped maze they encountered these
briefly appearing tall white objects
which we call towers and their job is to
count the towers because the reward will
always be on the side corresponding to
the highest tower count we also trained
them on a much simpler task that we call
visually guided tasks and this is
virtually identical to the accumulating
towers task it also contains the same
stimuli but here additionally we place a
visual guide at all visual guide that
the animals can always see and the guide
indicates where the reward is so this
completely removes the need for evidence
accumulation and working memory of the
stimuli we also trained them on an
intermediate task that is called the
memory guided task and here the animals
do not see towers they only see the
distal visual guide but this guy
disappears towards the end of the maze
such that the animal needs to remember
where it was so the first question that
we asked was what regions across the
dorsal cortex were necessary for the
animals to perform this task and here we
used optogenetic approaches to
systematically and in an unbiased
fashion inactivate 29 different cortical
areas very briefly only throughout
duration of the behavioural trials that
were randomly chosen within the
behavioral sessions and so here we saw
something very remarkable what I'm
showing you now as maps that summarize
the effects of in activating different
cortical areas on the behavioral
performance of these animals and here
what is important to note is that the
red circles indicate areas whose
inactivation caused significant
decreases in performance and so during
the easier visually guided task that
doesn't require working memory what we
noted is that primarily only the
inactivation of these very few cortical
areas that correspond to visual cortical
areas that process visual stimuli
affected the performance of the task and
in very stark contrast when we looked at
the two other tasks that require working
memory we noted very widespread effects
of an activating many different cortical
areas on the behavior next we wanted to
understand what underlying activity
patterns actually explain these large
differences in the effects of an
activation and to do this we used wide
field imaging to observe calcium
activity over the entire dorsal surface
of the cortex with spatial resolutions
of tens of microns and so the video that
I'm about to show you summarizes our
main findings here here the activity of
each pixel is color-coded such that the
yellow er it is the higher the activity
is and this is a video from a mouse that
is performing both the visually guided
task and the accumulating tower's tasks
within the same behavioral session and
the maze here will just serve to orient
you with respect to the timing so
specifically during the period while the
animals still experiencing two towers
what we saw in the visually guided tasks
is brief early activation of those very
same visual cortical areas that whose
inactivation resulted in decreases in
performance of this task but again in
stark contrast when these this Mouse was
performing the accumulating towers tasks
throughout the accumulating period that
is while they're gradually accumulating
sensory evidence we observed widespread
activation over the surface of the
cortex and then
we proceeded the show that this activity
is indeed related to evidence
accumulation computations so taken
together these findings show that more
complex tasks involving working memory
recruit more widespread computations
across the dorsal cortex you've just
heard from Lucas Pinto about how our
accumulating towers task appears to
involve many different cortical brain
regions how is it that these different
brain regions communicate and what is it
that they're saying to each other
suppose you record from 300 neurons in
each of two different brain regions what
are the shared signals between them and
what do those shared signals tell us
about their communication this is the
problem that dr. Steven Keeley who is
currently a postdoc in Jonathan pillows
group at Princeton has been addressing
the methods that Steven has been
developing are general that could be
used in many different tasks and studies
we're of course particularly excited to
apply them to our own tasks here Steven
to tell you about his work
hi today I'm going to tell you about
some work I've been doing with Jonathan
pillow in developing statistical tools
to find underlying structure and
multi-region neural population data I
want to first draw your attention to the
fact though over the past several
decades we've been able to record
simultaneously from more and more
neurons during behavioral tasks back in
the 60s and 70s we were only able to
record from a handful of neurons but now
there are many neural data sets that
contain five hundred or even thousand
neurons or more than thousand neurons in
this change in neural data underlines a
need to develop new statistical tools to
understand these neural data and so
today I'm going to talk to you about a
particular statistical tool that I've
been working on called a latent variable
model in a latent variable model we
describe high dimensional neural data so
a large number of neurons who are
described by a time series of spike
trains for each neuron we describe this
high dimensional neural data as having
some low dimensional structure so we can
see here this high dimensional journal
data set can be described by just in
evolving time trace in just two
dimensions we can find these meaningful
low description structures in neural
data and what this basically means is
though we may have a hundred numbers to
describe the neural data here we only
have two numbers to describe again this
entire population in this low
dimensional representation in these low
D representations help us understand how
neural activity represents information
about the world
these are parsimonious descriptions and
they're also easily visualizable so
they're a way to make sense of this
entire population of activity in order
to describe this I'm gonna step through
statistically how we describe a single
neuron first so to describe a single
neuron we're interested in
characterizing that neurons firing rate
we do this by describing its average
number of spikes per bin that we
expected to fire and we describe that
rate as smoothly evolving through time
so here I have an example of a firing
rate of a neuron sort of smoothly
evolving through time and we expect this
rate to give rise sort of randomly to
action potentials that have a higher
probability to fire when this firing
rate is high and a low probability of
firing when the
it is low so we would expect an example
neuron whose firing rate is described
with this trace to have a set of spikes
perhaps like this now again this is a
random process but the number of spikes
is proportional to the rate described
above now of course we aren't interested
in characterizing just the firing rate
of a single neuron these tools are
developed to understand populations of
neurons so here I have four different
firing rates describing four different
neurons in their corresponding spike
trains we expect in our statistical
methods to uncover low dimensional
structure of this population so what do
I mean by low dimensional structure well
in this case these four neurons can be
decomposed into two functions which I'm
calling latent one or latent two or X 1
and X 2 here by this decomposition what
I mean is that each firing rate is some
particular combination of these two
latent variables so we can see here that
this first rate is actually only a
component of latent one but the second
and third rates are weighted sums of
latent one in latent - and because all
of these rates for this entire
population are different weighted
combinations of latent one and latent
two we describe this for the set of four
firing rates is actually a two
dimensional population so this is so
these four spikes are actually two
dimensional population activity now I'm
now describing here exactly what I
described in the last slide are our
central goal for these class of methods
is to look at the spike trance and
decompose it into say we have these six
neurons decompose it into two latent
variables that have some weighted
combination this is now a matrix
operation describing a set of a a set of
weighted combinations of these two
Layton's describing the rates of each of
these neurons because these are rates
however we need to constrain them to be
non-negative so we put them through
what's called a non-linearity this
forces all of the numbers in here to be
non-negative and such that we have
valuable firing rates and we need that
to be non-negative because firing rates
cannot in fact for neural activity be
negative they have to be either zero or
positive so again the mapping is some
latent variables via some linear
combination of the say two latent
variables
put through some non-linearity to keep
the numbers positive and that describes
our firing rates and this is a smooth
low dimensional latent space and if
you're curious the mapping from the
firing rates to the spike trains is via
in homogeneous plus on process in order
to extend this class of methods to multi
multi region data I'll show you a
schematic for how we do that so here we
have the an example population from a
certain region of the brain I'm showing
for example neurons from say region one
and four spike trains from say region
two in order to decompose this into its
underlying latent structure well we
actually decompose it into three
different sets of underlying structures
so we assume some of the underlying
latent structure that's low dimensional
corresponds only to region one we assume
some of the underlying structure that's
low dimensional corresponds only to
region two and we assume some of the
underlying latent structures actually
shared between these regions and again
this goes through a weighted sum or some
combination some matrix operation that's
going to give me firing rates for each
of these neurons and each of these
firing rates is going to map to sorry so
so region two is only mapped the region
two latencies are only mapped to region
two activity the shared Leyton's are
only going to be are going to be mapped
to both regions and the region one
Layton's are only going to be mapped to
region one and again all of these smooth
firing rate curves are going to be
described via Poisson noise to represent
our entire neural population activity
and that is the general tool we are
going to use to uncover latent structure
that is both local to and shared between
many regions in the brain thank you in
what we've told you so far we've mostly
been thinking about cortical regions but
how about the rest of the brain dr.
merliss Oakland a postdoc in San Juans
group at Princeton has been thinking
about this problem and in particular she
has been thinking about the cerebellum
the cerebellum has long been thought of
as a motor structure involved in
controlling our motor acts but in recent
years is become more and more
appreciated that it also participates in
cognition and Sam Wong's group has been
one of the group's leading the efforts
in this direction in particular there
are parts of the cerebellum that are
strongly connected with regions of
cortex associated with cognition do they
play a role in the accumulating towers
task release has been studying this and
is here to tell you about her work
hi I will talk about the role of the
cerebellum in decision-making
specifically how cerebellar
representations evolve during learning
of an evidenced accumulation decision
making tasks everyday you need to
integrate cues from your environment to
make decisions such as when you are
crossing a street
we need to integrate the information
about the cars coming from right and
from the left in order to make decision
when it will be safe to cross a street
you might think by now that this is easy
to do so but maybe the video of this dog
will help you appreciate that's actually
learned behavior you did not always know
how to do this so how does the brain
actually learn how to integrate cues
from the environment and which brain
regions could be involved any one lab
were interested in a surveyor process is
contributing to non ultra functions such
as decision-making we have developed an
evidence accumulation decision making
tasks for the mice in which movement is
produced minds are head fixed and
sitting in a tube the evidence that I
need to integrate or accumulate over
time or air puffs deliver to their
whiskers the decision I need to make is
making right or left this is based on
where the whisker puffs are given if
they receive more air puffs to the right
whiskers they will need to make a
decision by looking right after several
weeks of training animals are doing very
well this task so does if they receive
more air puffs to the right side of the
task they will have a higher fraction of
right word decisions which is correct
we've also shown that performance that
sorry that cerebellar crisp one is
important for the performance of this
task if we opted genetically and
bilaterally inactivate crus one of the
cerebellum the animals are back at
chance level which is indicated here by
the blue line innocent and similar
psychometric curve so what goes on in
the brain when the animals performing
this task we have done somatic calcium
imaging in Perkins ourselves of crew
salon and during aq period indicated
here by the gray box some Purkinje cells
were invoked our activity and auto break
into cells room founder activity the
strength of this ramping up a ramping
down or the slope of this ramp is
correlated with house from the evidence
was during the Q period
we've now also replicated this finding
with in vivo electrophysiology using
certain protocols the higher temporal
resolution is technique provides has
shown us that our is also a sharp
increase in fine rate at the onset of
the Q period which always starts with
bilateral posts so the cerebellum is
definitely not the only region
contributing to kin period by increasing
its firing rate or showing revs up or
down this has also been shown for the
VTA the striatum and also several areas
of the neocortex are involved in
decision-making tasks like this so why
does a cerebellum also need to
contribute to this by showing Gramps
during acute period while the cerebellum
has bi-directional connections to the
frontal cortices I'm highlighting the
ascending pathways here in green for
instance Purkinje cells increased one
can projects to the cerebellar nuclei in
this case the dentate nucleus which
projects to several nuclei natella
thalamus which can then proceed as
information to frontal and parietal
cortices there are also many areas back
for now I will highlight on the dentate
nucleus and role this play is in an
evidence accumulation decision-making
task so when an animal is very well
trained there ramps up and down also in
the dentate nucleus similar to what we
found in broken t cells increase 1 this
is an example once cell the dentate
nucleus of a trained Mouse hare are the
parameters of the tasks explained the
task X starts with an audio cue to
indicate that the animal needs to pay
attention there's a cue period which
starts and ends with bilateral puffs and
after short delayed in lick birds arrive
and the animals are able to make an
executor decision as an example from one
cell through one our training session
and several trials we see a sharp
increase in relation to the audio cue as
well to the bilateral parts at the onset
and at the end of the key period
throughout this cue period here we see
an increase in firing rate so it starts
with approximately baseline frame rate
and then increases also we see a lot of
activity when animals licking with
several cells in the dentate nucleus and
indeed some cells are imbibed activity
while other cells her bowel narrativity
but what happens to these tasks related
dynamics when animals actually learning
a task what would happen to very first
time the animals in this setup as I said
before when animal is actually doing a
trained task they have begun several
weeks of training and they have gone
through eight different levels of this
task in a very first session animals
have never been in a setup before
they've never had an air puff delivered
to their whiskers in this way and it's
also the first time they receive a water
drop in from the lake ports in his task
there's still audio cue at the beginning
the cue period is much shorter it's only
one second now but it can be followed by
hints which are opposed to the whiskers
in the correct side which will continue
until the animal actually licks I will
show you now this example for then
technically a cell in a very first day
of training we see an audio cube that
are is not really visible response to
the audio cue however there's a strong
increase in fine great threat first half
the cue period and there's increased
self load by a slow decrease in tilt
back to baseline here when animals
making we actually seen what another
increase we also see examples of cells
which do the opposite so here for
instance this example of a cell the
dentate nucleus on a very first day of
training that shows some indication of
an increase in firing rates to the audio
cue german first half the cube period
instead of an increase this cell
actually responds with a decrease in
firing rate which then returns to the
baseline levels at the end of the cue
period dose we also see cells ramping up
and bound in event a nucleus already on
the very first day of training to
conclude i have shown you that in
well-trained mice both Purkinje cells
increase one and neurons in event a
nucleus show ramps during evidence
accumulation and at the earlier stages
of training even on a very first session
there's already some indication of ramps
in the dentate nucleus cells thank you
in the behaviors that we've been talking
about our mice are motivated by water
awards
our reward related circuits also
involved this question led dr. ben angle
Hart a postdoc in the tank and Whitin
labs at Princeton to wonder whether the
ventral tegmental area which is a region
long thought to be involved in reward
processing is also involved in the
accumulating tires tasks to address this
he imaged from neurons in the VTA to
look at their activity while must
perform the task and as he will tell you
he found some very interesting results
showing that not only was their activity
correlated with reward but also with
many many other different aspects of the
task here is been to tell you about his
work hi I will talk about the dopamine
in the brain and new experiments were
performing on a Sunday role of dopamine
release in neurons helping produce
complex behavior popcorn is a molecule
which acts as a key neurotransmitter in
the brain it is produced by a group of
neurons called dopamine neurons which
are located primarily in the midbrain
pig brain structure which is because
further across species throughout
evolution these neuro stem release
dopamine to other important brain
regions such as destroy them as well as
the prefrontal cortex we know that
dopamine is important for normal brain
function because many brain disorders
are characterized by dopamine
dysfunction most famously Parkinson's
disease also others such as addiction
sephrillian ADHD and many more
correspondingly we know for many
clinical and pharmacological studies are
many behavioral processes which depend
on correct document function if you
called motor control working memory
attention decision-making and many
others these findings raise a
fundamental question which is how does
the activity of dopamine neurons and
help mediate all these different
behaviors walls previous studies that
have looked at the activity of open ears
during behavior found responses mostly
related to reward processing here's one
representative study which shows that
many different open ears have very
strong responses to reward
secondly this Neera seems to responding
in the exact same way
this has been a consistent finding
across studies which has suggested that
dog renews act as a homogeneous function
population although Bernier do the same
thing in order to respond reward
processing now this picture does not
explain how dog owners camilli eight
different behavioral processes that we
have discussed before fo we proceed to
perform new experiments which involve
recording of dopamine human activity in
a context behavioral task this task is a
virtual Timmy's task for mice which
three run down the same of the teammates
and they are presented with random kills
either to the left to the right you know
the teammates they have to turn to stay
with the remote keys to obtain the
reward here's how the task Luke likes
from the Masters perspective it is a
complex behavior which involves many
different behavior violence such as
navigation in the teammate he managed a
locomotion of the mouse the reward cues
they ever seen the task they reward
history and the reward itself and recall
that the volunteers are supposed to be a
homogeneous function population but all
new is responding the same way that is
not what we found in this task here are
all the news that we recorded in the
test I'm showing the responses to each
beam annex locomotion of the mouse first
color coded is to respond strength of
Anu with clorine debating stronger
responses as you can see a strong
responses to kinematics awesome he knows
have weak responses the same pattern
holds true for position is the response
for the position of the mouse along the
mains interestingly same years do not
seem to respond strongly both to a
neutral position we see the same pattern
for the responses to other behavior
variables such as the reward in the
previous trial the cue that I presented
to the mouse though was the accuracy
intense and so in all these variables
that occurred during the navigation
based decision making part of the task
we find a very diverse response perform
but if you seem to respond to the
different things
also look at the responses to reward
which counts at the end of the trial
when we do that we see a very different
picture
but almost all news have very strong
reward responses consistent with the
previous literature which are shown that
the bunions have unit from responses for
because electron is somewhere there any
structure to these responses but we have
specific subpopulations which has
similar response profiles to that we
group the news using a clustering
algorithm that five clusters explain
best data or we ordered a matrix based
on the classes that we find which are
color-coded on the right we see that
each cluster is associated primarily
with a single behavior variable the perk
during the navigation portion of the
times for example nearest belonging to
the red cluster are special corral with
climatic responses us belonging to the
green cluster primarily with position
responses and so on so we find that
there are specialized subpopulations of
learners the iterative responses to
different behavior feature or fireball
in the task all of the news have
strongly war responses consistent with
the previous five bonus eyes that this
is relation could be substrate that
explains how the single molecule that is
dopamine and help reduce complex
behavior and all the different
behavioral processes associated with
dopamine when we currently performing
new experiments
brain regions of particular interest for
Donowitz lab include not only the
ventral tegmental area that he just
heard about but also the striatum a
postdoc in the witan lab dr. scott
balkan and iris stone a graduate student
that has shared between the Witten lab
and jonathan the pillows lab have been
working on data from the striatum their
preliminary results suggest that animals
go through bouts of very very different
states of behavior and of neural circuit
dynamics as they perform the accumulate
hours tasks
this suggests that we should analyze and
think about our data very differently
according to which of the different
states the animal is in thus although
they have been developing their methods
for data from the striatum their results
could perhaps apply across the entirety
of the project
here to tell you about scott balkans and
iris stone's work is professor alana
Witten
hi I'm gonna tell you about work from my
lab and Jonathan pillows lab on the roll
of the stratum and evidence accumulation
so why are we interested in the striatum
in evidence accumulation so the striatum
is I think a very interesting structure
that's part of the basal ganglia which
are which is basically composed of these
two it's part of these two parallel
feedback loops on to cortex one loop is
called the indirect pathway its schema
ties with these yellow neurons and the
other is called the direct pathway and
what's interesting is that these two
feedback loops provide positive and
negative feedback to cortex and this is
interesting in the person from the
perspective of evidence accumulation
because these feedback loops may have
opposing effects on the accumulation of
evidence in cortex so as a first step
towards testing this idea we wanted to
inhibit the direct and indirect pathway
during the towers task first in the
dorsal striatum and what we found were
huge effects from inhibiting the
striatum where you get opposite decision
biases with bias in the direction it's
the lateral to the inhibition site if
you inhibit the direct pathway and
contralateral if you inhibit the
indirect pathway which is consistent
with the concept that these two pathways
have opposing effects on cortex and
really interestingly the same exact
manipulation in the same animals but on
a team aids with a visual guide rather
than the evidence accumulation did not
lead to any bias and decisions
suggesting that this isn't a motor
structure but instead it's really
involved in the decision-making process
so this says that the direct and
indirect pathway have opposing effects
on decision-making but does this deter
is this determined by the sub region of
the striatum if we did the exact same
experiment but in the ventral rather
than the dorsal striatum in that case
there weren't decision-making biases
there is actually very little effect if
anything laser cause the animals to be a
little less
sensitive to evidence so what this means
is a little stratum has big effects on
decision-making that depend on cell type
and sub-region we thought this was
really exciting and to try to better
understand these effects we wanted to
use computational modeling both to
better understand the behavior and
better understand the effect of the
straddle inhibition on the behavior so
specifically with jonathan pillows lab
we've been using a generalized linear
model combined with a hidden Markov
model to discover discrete behavioral
states during this task for example oh
this is a schematic of the hidden Markov
model part of the model where each
circle here is a different trial and you
can think of different states where
there's different probabilities of
emitting a choice for example maybe and
say one there could be a more
probability of a right choice and say to
a higher probability of a left choice
and this is a hidden Markov model where
the animal is more likely to stay in the
same state than transition to a new
state and on top of the hidden Markov
model there's also a generalized linear
model such that external covariance like
the sensory evidence or the previous
choice or whether the laser was on also
influences the animals choice and the
influence of these Co various depends on
specific weighting that gets learned by
the GLM and which are different for
different states so this basically
allows decision-making to be modeled and
apply a process where the animal is in
different states at different periods in
time with different weightings between
the sensory and external covariance and
the animals choice what we find is that
this model does a really good job
explaining the data and discovers
different behavioral states at different
points in time this is just one example
session where the animals briefly in
state one early on in the session but
then spends most of the session in state
two so what are states 1 2 & 3 here I'm
showing you the psychometric curves from
the same set of animals but separated
out by these states and you can see that
their state 1 is a state with very low
performance where they don't do a lot of
evidence accumulation where they do the
task much better in state 2 in state 3
and what's really interesting as these
different states have different effects
of stimuli of inhibiting the striatum
and
basically this suggests that the
striatum contributes differentially to
these different states and mostly
contributes to this state 3 where the
animals are doing a good job performing
the task but when you inhibit the
striatum their behavior gets really
messed up unlike these other states
where the striatum is less involved in
their performance so what have we
learned so far about the striatum the
dorsal striatum if you inhibit that
generates a huge decision bias the
direct and indirect pathways have
opposite effects on the animals decision
whereas an essential striatum you don't
get a decision of a Tobias when you
inhibit so therefore the effect of the
striatum on decision-making depends on
pathway and also depends on sub region
finally the gel mm-hmm the suggests that
the dorsal striatum continued
contributes to behavior and generates
these biases in specific behavioral
States thank you very much to listening
for listen the tops
a typical neuron in the brain is
connected to 1,000 to 10,000 other
neurons
how do those connections shape the
neurons activities adrian warner a
postdoc in sebastian stone and david
tanks lab has been addressing this
problem by working on a high-throughput
system to first use imaging to record
the activities of many neurons while an
animal performs a task and then use
electron microscopy and semi-automated
machine learning reconstruction methods
to identify all the connections between
the recorded neurons as he will tell you
about in the next talk he has been
developing this approach for a task
other than the accumulating Terrace task
but the difficult part is the method
itself so we are very excited to see him
develop it and to then apply it to the
accumulating towers in a hearing Puffs
tasks for a mechanistic understanding of
brain function on a circuit level it is
of fundamental importance to understand
the direction of information flow in
those circuits harmonica hall was one of
the first neuroscientists that attempted
to infer the direction of information
flow from morphological reconstructions
of neurons he used light microscopy to
observe the detailed morphology of Golgi
stain neurons and painted and
reconstructed their shapes in his
tradition they are building a functional
connectives pipeline here at the
Princeton Neuroscience Institute that
combines in vivo functional functional
imaging with subsequent volume electron
microscopy based circuit reconstruction
in the same specimen the typical
workflow is as follows we start off with
behavioral training and multiphoton
calcium imaging in behaving animals
we then perfuse the animals and fix the
tissue with aldehydes stained the tissue
blocks with heavy metals and section the
blocks into ultra thin sections
typically through 30 to 40 nanometers
thin sections that are then imaged in
our high throughput electron microscopy
facility the resulting petabyte scale
data sets are then processed by our
automated image processing
infrastructure that also automatically
reconstructs the dense morphology and
the connectivity between those neurons
using deep convolutional networks
finally we map the measured multiphoton
cut some activity on to the
reconstructed neurons in order to
perform a detail function to structure
analysis in one of the ongoing from for
chronic dogs projects here at pni we aim
to reconstruct the neural circuit
underlying sequential neuronal activity
in retrospect cortex of mice performing
different working memory tasks in a
virtual reality setting on the left you
see an example of a delayed match the
sample with two alternative force choice
tasks when the trial starts the mouse
runs along the linear track and enters a
sample period in in which particular
pattern in this case the vertical stripe
pattern is shown on the walls as the
Mars continues running it enters that
delay period in which the sample is
switched off when the mouse continues
running towards the end of the linear
track two arms appear and the mouse has
to turn to the one arm that has the same
pattern on the walls as has been
previously shown during the sample
period in order to get a reward we image
the calcium activity of hundreds of
neurons simultaneously in different
cortical layers while the mouse is
performing this task thereby we find
sample specific sequences of neurons
that are actives throughout the whole
experiment the sequences during the
delay period however are of particular
interest because we think they represent
correspond to some sort a some form of
working memory there from different
circuit models have been proposed that
could generate this kind of neuron
sequences the most famous one is
probably the sin v chain in which layers
of neurons are connected in a
feed-forward fashion in order to
propagate your own activity from layer
to layer alternatively the neurons could
be her inner self called ring attractor
network in which combinations of local
excitatory connections between
neighboring neurons long-range
inhibition and as
connectivity results in bumps of
activity that move in a temporal ordered
fashion
similarly random networks can be trained
to generate these kind of sequences by
modifying only a small fraction of the
overall synapses in order to validate or
falsify any of these models we need to
measure the activity of hundreds of
neurons simultaneously and we need to
reconstruct the dense connectivity
between the neurons for this we apply
the functional electronics approach
volume electromicroscope is the only
technique that has sufficient resolution
to resolve each individual synapse and
can cover sufficiently large field of
view that contain entire local cortical
circuits we therefore are building a
high-throughput transmission electron
microscopy facility here in Princeton
consisting of several transmission
electron microscopes the collective
image acquisition rate of several
terabytes per hour this is sufficient to
acquire high resolution stacks of cubic
millimeter size tissue blocks on a
regular basis on the right you see such
a large section of a piece of mouse
retina that has been imaged in less than
ten minutes with one of our transmission
electron microscopes as you can see the
resolution is sufficient to even resolve
ultra structural features such as
endoplasmic reticula mitochondria the
crista and of course synapse and the
vesicles processing and reconstructing
this petabytes I searched image stacks
requires specialized image analysis
tools our lab has developed deep
convolution network based automated
segmentation algorithms that
automatically reconstruct the morphology
of the neurons and the synapses in this
large electromicroscopy stacks here you
see a subset of 360 pyramidal cells that
have been reconstructed from a large
electron microscopy dataset that has
been acquired by our collaborators at
the Allen Institute for brain science
these neurons are from layer 2 3 in Mass
visual
or text with this automated analysis
tools at hands we can now start
performing detailed functions through
structured analysis of entire local
cortical circuits for example we can
look at the higher-order organization of
excitatory to excitatory connections in
layer 2 or 3 we hope you enjoyed
listening to these six different
snapshots of work going on within the
broader overall project as we strive to
understand working memory and
decision-making and how they're
implemented in the brain each of the
snapshots has its own motivation its own
person or persons leading it and its own
development yet they're all closely
bound together by using tasks that
involve accumulating pulses of sensory
evidence and therefore they all inform
us about working memory and
decision-making we didn't tell you today
about our current efforts to develop
models both statistical and biophysical
that integrate information across many
different experiments and many different
brain regions developing such models is
one of our important long-term goals
and each of the snapshots has
contributed fundamentally towards that
goal thank you again for listening